pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
c'est mercredi et le mercredi c'est un
moment de partage encore plus intense
dans votre communauté
des épis curieuse et des épis curieux
puisque le mercredi je réponds à vos
questions allez c'est parti
[Musique]
on commence avec une question d'aline
sur twitter dit jamie quel est le sujet
le plus complexe que tu ai eu à traiter
sans réfléchir est la matière
dès lors que l'on rentre dans
l'infiniment petit tout devient
compliqué à expliquer tout simplement
parce que vous le savez quand j'explique
quelque chose j'aime bien conceptualiser
j'aime bien utiliser des images sauf que
quand on rentre dans un atome dans les
phénomènes qui se déroule à l'intérieur
d'un à tourner la mécanique quantique
quand on commence à parler de quarks et
de gluons alors là ça devient très
complexe parce que ça ne correspond à
rien de ce que l'on connaisse donc c'est
très très compliqué et j'avoue que
lorsque j'ai eu à traiter ce sujet et
bien j'ai un peu ramé dit jamie qu'est
ce qu'une biotechnologies alors en fait
les biotechnologies ce sont des
technologies qui utilisent le vivant
pour produire des choses le meilleur
exemple c'est le fromage et c'est très
certainement la première biotechnologies
qui a été utilisée par l'homme tout
simplement parce que ce sont des micro
organismes qui transforme le lait en
fromage dont vous le voyez on fait appel
ou vivant à des micro organismes pour
transformer le lait en fromage déjà mis
depuis combien de temps porte tu t'es
fameuses lunettes si reconnaissable et
bien je porte des lunettes depuis l'âge
de 5 ans mais toutes premières lunettes
était ronde j'ai eu beaucoup de lunettes
rondes
mais c'est vrai que je fais quelques
petite entorse à cette règle et si vous
fouillez un petit peu dans les archives
la télé bien vous verrez que dans
certaines émissions
je porte des lunettes un peu noir ont
plus carré mais sincèrement je préfère
les lunettes rondes une question de
maillots paul de 8 sur un stade est
jamais qu est ce qu un trou noir
alors pour ceux qui auraient trop de
mémoire où ils ignoraient comme vous
paul sûrement eh bien j'ai réalisé une
vidéo sur ce sujet pendant le premier
confinement j'ai publié aux alentours du
10 avril si ma mémoire ne me fait pas
défaut
une question de volkan sur youtube dit
jamie quelle est ta plus grande peur
alors je vais vous faire une petite
confidence mais surtout ne le répétez à
personne
j'ai peur des rats et des souris mais
vraiment très peur s'il a une souris
passer à mes pieds je rebondirai je me
bleux tirait dans les étagères une autre
peur que j'ai eue lors d'un tournage
mais une vraie peur aussi
c'est d'un animal à peu plus volumineux
que la souris c'est un ours polaire lors
d'un tournage pour le monde de jamie au
svalbard un tournage sur les animaux
sauvages et les hommes
il nous
devions films et des ours polaires à un
moment donné on voit un ours polaire
le réalisateur nous quitte avec le guide
qui était armé pour s'approcher de
l'ours polaire et je me se retrouver nez
à nez avec l'ours polaire à une
trentaine de mètres
j'avais avec moi l'ethnologue nicolas
dubreuil qui m'a dit à mon top tu te
lèves et tu pousses de grands cris car
évidemment nos scooters étaient eux à
une centaine de mètres et on était
incapable de partir en courant pour
remonter sur les scooters
heureusement l'ours blanc nous à
regarder tranquillement et l'a fait demi
tour et tout s'est très bien terminée si
vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche